so the topic of this video today is
really going to be an overview of
photosynthesis this diagram here kind of
illustrates the things that we are going
to be discussing so let's go ahead and
get started
so the sun gives off a wide variety of
types of energy and the energy travels
across space in the form of a wave and
you can see the different kinds of
energy radio microwave infrared and so
on now this presentation we're going to
focus our attention on the visible light
that is released from the sun because
those are the wavelengths that actually
power photosynthesis
so when we focus on the light given off
by the Sun the visible light visible
light is also known as white light now
you might know that white light is
actually a mixture of something called
Roy G Biv which is the colors of the
rainbow the Spectrum here red orange
yellow green blue indigo violet so white
light is actually a mixture of all these
colors together well how do we know this
well if you shine a white light source
into a prism a rainbow comes out the
other side
just like you see in this animation
white light is entering from the left
and because of the curvature of the
prism the wavelengths of the other
colors of light begin to separate notice
the red wavelength is longer and the
Violet wavelengths are more narrow
and in this picture right here you can
actually see white light coming in and
on the left hand side a rainbow coming
out so this is how we know that a white
light is a mixture of all these colors
you know you can actually see a similar
effect water in the air
can act like a prism and separate the
colors of white light into a rainbow
after it rains it's very common to see
rainbows and in this picture near a
waterfall all the water and all the Mist
that's in the air is separating the
sunlight and you can actually see a
rainbow
so colors of light are either reflected
or absorbed by objects you know in this
example when we shine light onto a leaf
we see reflected light and in this
example green light is reflecting off of
the leaves but the other colors are
absorbing into the leaves well why do
bananas appear yellow
so the reason these bananas appear
yellow is because when light is shined
on them yellow light is reflected the
wavelength of yellow is reflected the
other colors are absorbed
so in this example when light is shined
on these balloons the reason the
balloons appear blue is because they're
reflecting the blue wavelength the other
colors are absorbed
so white is an interesting color so
white objects they appear white because
they reflect all the wavelengths and all
the wavelengths enter our eyes and our
brain interprets this as the color white
so the opposite effect are objects that
are colored black when light shines on a
black object no light reflects into our
eyes and and we and the black object
absorbs the colors and we don't see any
light at all and and that's we interpret
as the color black
okay so when we relate this to
photosynthesis you know most plants have
green leaves which means when sunlight
Shines on them the reason they appear
green is because they're reflecting
green light it's the other colors the
red the orange the yellow the blue the
indigo violet that are absorbing the
other colors are absorbing into the
leaves and it's really the other the
other colors that are really going to
drive and power photosynthesis
so here's a really interesting graph and
what this graph is showing at the bottom
of the graph the wavelengths of visible
light and the numbers correspond to
various colors and when you look at the
line graph notice there's a peak around
400 nanometers well that's the
wavelength for blue light and notice
there's another Peak around 700
nanometers that's the wavelength for red
light so what this graph is showing me
is the rate of photosynthesis is highest
in red light and in blue light so red
and blue are the colors of light that
are most stimulating in terms of a
plant's ability to do photosynthesis
notice there's a dip or a valley in the
middle of the graph around 550
nanometers ironically that's the
wavelength for green so the color that
we most uh relate to plants you know
green leaves the color that we most
think of when in terms of plants green
is actually the least powerful to them
in photosynthesis because leaves are
green most green sunlight is reflected
very little green light ever actually
absorbs for them to do for you for them
to do photosynthesis with the green
light
so when we look at a general definition
of photosynthesis you know it's the
process that converts solar energy into
glucose and this formula here outlines
photosynthesis and in the reactants we
have carbon dioxide and water and in the
presence of sunlight will produce
sugars such as glucose and oxygen
well who who performs photosynthesis
well these are the autotrophs now we
typically think of plants as doing
photosynthesis but they're not the only
ones algae
phytoplankton the basis of ocean food
webs kelp kelp can grow into these
enormous underwater forests and even
some bacteria known as cyanobacteria are
photosynthetic so there's a lot more
autotrophs than just plants
so photosynthesis is also what we call
an endergonic chemical reaction and what
that means is that photosynthesis
requires the input of energy from the
picture I'm implying that sunlight
sunlight is the energy that is input to
power photosynthesis
and when we talk about the end result
what's created well oxygen which is a
waste gas and simple sugars like glucose
but when we zoom out into the leaf we
find some peculiar pores on their
Underside these pores will open and
close and they're called stomata and
it's how they exchange gases it's how
they take in carbon dioxide from the
atmosphere and when they produce oxygen
as a waste through these stomata
openings they give off the oxygen
created so it's through these pores that
they exchange gas with the atmosphere
okay so let's actually get into the
process of photosynthesis you know as an
overview you're probably going to see a
diagram very similar to this well we're
going to be able to break photosynthesis
down into two separate reactions if this
is a chloroplast inside of the
chloroplasts there are internal parts
and on the left side of my diagram are
the parts involved in the light
dependent reactions of photosynthesis
like the name implies sunlight is is
needed it's unlike this is dependent
upon sunlight
and then on the right hand side of the
chloroplast this would be the light
independent reactions also known as the
Calvin cycle so throughout the rest of
these notes we're going to make sense
out of this summary diagram that you see
right here
so let's first start talking about the
light dependent reactions well if we
identify parts of a chloroplast the
liquidy interior is known as the stroma
much like the cytoplasm of a cell
there's a liquidy interior
and then there are these structures
these little discs that are stacked on
top of each other called a thylakoid so
there's a thylakoid disc there's a
thylakoid disc there's one there's one
there's one and the entire stack of
thylakoids is what's called a granum so
if you ever come across the word the
words thylakoids and granum well I hope
this gives you a better understanding of
what they are they are parts inside of a
chloroplast
so when we focus on the light dependent
reactions first of all the location is
going to be the membrane of a thylakoid
and that's because the membranes are
loaded with chlorophyll molecules
perhaps you've heard of chlorophyll from
middle school chlorophyll is the
molecule that actually absorbs sunlight
so with the addition of sunlight and H2O
water and various enzymes now the
enzymes I didn't picture in my animation
but this is going to start a chemical
reaction known as the light dependent
reactions and in the process some oxygen
waste is created it's kind of fun
because the O's for the oxygen the
oxygen atoms actually come from water
the water molecule gets broken down and
the oxygens are released as waste and
then a molecule that abbreviated any dph
is created and notice in the animation
it's released into the stroma nadph is a
pretty big molecular molecule here you
can see its name nicoteramide adenine
dinucleotide phosphate 21 carbons 29
hydrogens and so on the formula of nadph
I'm not going to test you on that but
the importance of NAD nadph is that it's
a hydrogen carrier it's carrying a lot
of hydrogens and those hydrogens are
going to go into the stroma where we're
going to have where they're going to be
used in the second part the second
reaction of photosynthesis
also molecules of ATP are produced and
so you have really three things that are
created oxygen waste nadph and ATP
well now let's focus on the light
independent reactions also known as the
Kelvin cycle and so the location of the
Calvin cycle the location of the light
independent reactions is the liquidy
interior of the chloroplast the stroma
and we now have the input of carbon
dioxide you've probably known for a
while that plants and other autotrophs
absorb and take in carbon dioxide and
here's where they need it they take in
carbon dioxide plus the ATP from the
light dependent reactions plus the nadph
from the light dependent reactions and
this starts what is known as the Calvin
cycle a series of chemical reactions in
order to create glucose
C6H12O6 in the Calvin cycle this is
where the glucose is created but to keep
photosynthesis going the H the hydrogens
from nadph are used and the nadp goes
back into the light light dependent
reactions
and then the ATP when the ATP is broken
down the ADP the ADP also returns to the
light dependent reaction so there's a
lot of moving Parts here but when you
look at the diagram I just showed you I
hope it makes a lot more sense now
so now that we've kind of walked through
the summary here I hope this diagram
from a few minutes ago makes a little
more sense on the left again is the
light dependent reactions and if we just
kind of read through it light dependent
reactions were is where sunlight and
water create oxygen waste nadph and ATP
and then we move to the right hand side
the light independent reactions also
known as the Calvin cycle
this is where ATP nadph and carbon
dioxide from the atmosphere are used to
create glucose the glucose is then
released into the cytoplasm of the cell
and the glucose you'll see what its
purpose will be for in a moment
okay so what do plants and autotrophs
use their glucose for well here's a bad
little clip art drawing here of a cell
here's the nucleus the central vacuole
the green parts are the chloroplasts the
orange parts are the mitochondria well a
chloroplast will perform photosynthesis
and create glucose but notice where the
glucose goes It goes into a mitochondria
the mitochondria will then perform
cellular respiration and release a whole
heap a whole bunch of ATP that the cell
can use for its energy needs and so
really plants make glucose in order to
then do cellular respiration to make ATP
so that makes cellular respiration and
ATP really important and we'll learn
about that in another lesson
so one of your tasks is you should be
able to fill in this blank diagram here
pause the video and try to go through
this of course you can check your
answers based on the diagram from a few
moments ago
and so there you go there's a little
summary of photosynthesis and the light
dependent and light independent
reactions hope you found this helpful if
you're in my class you know try these
questions I'm happy to check your
answers before school or after school
one day thanks for watching